hello everyone a very warm good morning
good afternoon or good evening in
whichever part of the world you are
i would like to welcome you all to the
extensive 3 days workshop on ngs single
cell data analysis and scrnsc project
support
this workshop is designed to highlight
the efficient and effective data
analysis using t-bioinfo workflows to
analyze single-cell rna data
so twice a year our community needs to
review innovation in bioinformatics
education and provides students with an
outlook on careers and research
trajectories rooted in computational
biology
the omics research symposium is an event
aimed at bringing together this network
of experts educators and students from
all around the world to learn from each
other interact and discuss advances in
this seat
and this is the time period we hold
various workshops to prep up students
researchers and faculty
so in today's workshop we will learn
about an overview of the current scrnsc
technologies basic overview of pipelines
for processing raw reads into expression
values quality control of single cell
rna seq data dimensionality reduction
and clustering techniques
we have practical sessions that will use
case study approach using curated
project data set
to learn about generating a table of
expression from raw fast q files and
perform subsequent analysis of the
stable of gene and iso from expression
we will cover standard statistical
methods of analysis like differential
gene expression as well as advanced data
mining and machine learning for large
scale data sets
so before we begin with today's workshop
let me introduce myself and find biotech
for those who are joining us for the
very first time
my name is sunalika ray and i'm the
omixlogic community manager i'm
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of
our bioinformatics community that is
managed by pine biot
we are a u.s based bioinformatics
company who is working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
omix launch of research-based training
programs are the result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
and over the past several years we have
had the privilege of working with a
number of organizations developing a
training program for research oriented
students faculty and democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible to thousands of students and
faculty around the world
the training has been completed by over
15 000 participants from 162 countries
and over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
[Music]
the training follows a project-based
learning approach using research grade
tools to analyze data from top peer
reviewed journals
it has been completed in six different
specialization tracks which include
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
now to introduce the founders and the
team members of the company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and one of his major
projects is the establishment of topper
bioinformatics research center which has
been at the core of what we do
dr leonard brotzky is the director of
the tribal bioinformatics research
center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics
our platform is a hard work by some of
the people mentioned here on the right
julia panna who was an expert
bioinformatician avi tatovsky who leads
the development of the t by info
platform dr mohit mazumdar is an
experienced bioinformatician with
multiple publications and top
peer-reviewed journals he has been
developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor and project
lead for omix logic training and
research fellowship
dr raghavendran is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large-scale analysis of
multi-atomic data and data science
methods in precision oncology and
protein dna structural bioinformatics
so now let's gear up for today's session
first of all you all need to sign up on
the omixlogic learn portal
that will give you access to the
omixlogic courses which includes
resources on bioinformatics precision
medicine multi-omics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics and
ecogenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using art and python and
example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
throughout the workshop you will be
given the directions to access the t by
info platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of transactomics
data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
club infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
so now before i hand over the stage to
the mentors to get started with the
session
let's just quickly sign up on the
omixlogic learn portal
so that we can follow along the
resources that are shared by the mentors
and also practice
along
so for those who are joining for the
very first time i just space the link in
the chat box thank you just see
now let me give a quick demo of how you
can create an account on the portal real
quick and get started with the training
with the access to the resources
so by clicking on the link that ojasmi
has shared in the chat box
you will be able to look at this page
you need to click on the login button
that will redirect you to create your
account
now either you can create an account for
yourself by putting in the details
required or simply use any of your
social media accounts to sign up i'll be
doing it with my google account
for those who have already created their
accounts please let me know in the chat
box by sending a one or years maybe so
that i know that you have an account
already and others can take their time
to create an account for yourself so
that you can follow the resources that
the mentors talk about today in the
session
[Music]
i'll be waiting for the responses in the
chat box
thank you darshani for your response
for those who have already created their
account let's just quickly uh look at
how you have to have a complete profile
that will help you with your
certification process
and also help us monitor your progress
so when you click on your mail address
that is given in the top menu bar you
will be redirected to a profile section
you need to make sure that you have an
updated profile picture your name should
be in title case because this is the
same format that will reflect in your
certificate please make sure that your
name is not in capitals or small letters
connect your social media accounts and
also add a brief file about yourself
that could include your educational
background or your research interests
maybe that will help us and the mentors
to learn more about you
and with every coursework that you take
on the portal you will be able to look
at your progress here in your profile
section and as a part of the workshop
you should be able to look at the badge
of the workshop in your profile which
will give you access to the recordings
and also the resources for one month
now let's begin with today's session
now i would like to pass on the stage to
mr elia brodsky ceo pine biotech we'll
talk about single cell transcriptomic
data analysis research support over to
you india
thank you so much
and uh welcome everyone to this
i will start off by giving you a brief
introduction to single cell seek
just one of the types of data that you
can analyze at the single cell
level and i'll focus on
both some of the analytical challenges
and the research questions that are
being now discovered i'll introduce some
data sets i'll talk in detail about some
conceptual things that you have to know
when you're trying to analyze data and
i'll introduce you to the resources that
you can benefit from just trying to
understand how
methods of analysis actually fit in to
the full overview of how this data
should be analyzed and what are
challenges associated with that
so as soon as already mentioned we have
a portal called omixlogic that is
focused on the on the logic of analysis
behind many of these trending omics data
types
and the reason we have this portal is to
help researchers that come from a more
of a biological background to appreciate
some of the methods in computational
biology and find data sets that could
help them advance their research ideas
so we hope that as a student as a
researcher you will be able to learn the
basic concepts and quickly try to
practically apply these analysis methods
to a data set that you have selected so
that's what we're going to do today
we're look we're going to look at the
analysis part and we're going to look at
the data side as well
and the second reason is because
we believe that the ideas in
computational biology are becoming an
integral part of uh a research
and and so the data part of it the data
science part is critical but to get
started you don't have to be an engineer
you have to be
proficient in coding you don't have to
know everything there is to know about
statistics but you do have to develop an
intuition about these different
approaches
and the second audience that i'm going
to talk to are engineers people that
understand the technical part really
well
and would like to understand how to
apply what they know about the data
analysis to specifically biomedical
research data and i think single cell
data really represents one of the major
trends that we are experiencing right
now with explosion of computational
challenges methods and approaches that
any engineer can participate and bring a
lot of effective solutions too so
exciting field to be a part of
so i'll start off by introducing uh the
coursework that we already have so those
of you that already know bulk rna-seq
will benefit from advancing your uh
your kind of practical hands-on
experience with single cell data
and the reason is that it builds on a
lot of the concepts that you should be
familiar with from basic transcriptomic
data analysis but you really have to
read both the differences in the data
and some of the methodology that is
going to be used to analyze identify
patterns and then be able to interpret
biological uh patterns what what could
you actually find in this kind of data
right that's the the question that we're
going to talk about today
so in the bulk rna-seq
as you remember the major objective is
to process reeds
that come from a tissue or a collection
of cells so let's say cell culture or
tissue
and then try to understand typically at
the difference between condition and
control
what are some amplified pathways or gene
sets so that's the standard approach in
rna-seq right you kind of have to create
a matrix of gene expression levels and
then you can compare and contrast
between different conditions
now in cell what happens is that the
resolution of your data
becomes much much more specific and so i
like this analogy that i heard
um that entering temperature and
averaging it across the whole hospital
right where i can say i have
dead people
in the hospital in the morgue i have
people with fever very high fever and
maybe the infectious disease department
and i have average temperature maybe in
other races as well so if i measure the
average temperature across all of these
different conditions i will get a normal
temperature
but at single cell level i am going to
start to distinguish between the
departments and i can say here's my
acute patient uh you know department
here's the dead
and here are the normal people right so
i can start to distinguish and that is
really one of the benefits of having sex
resolution but how do we achieve that
how do we actually produce data that can
help us see some of these differences
well in
2019 i believe this paper came out that
kind of did a review of many different
methods of single cell data preparation
and you will see here how
first these were very manual methods so
methods that people had to you know take
individual kind of several cells and try
to separate them and so forth and all
the way to more and more automated
methods and so today when we look at the
data that you are typically going to
encounter
it comes from a specific machine that is
designed to optimize automate and
increase the number of cells and the
accuracy of barcoding but here you can
see that you know throughout from 2009
which the first paper that was published
on single cell is in the middle of 2009
all the way to 2017
you can see an exponential growth of
these single cell approaches and so in
2019 or sorry in 2017 actually when this
paper was published uh they compiled all
of these protocols that went from you
know very manual again to more and more
automated and you can appreciate now
that whenever you take a data set that
is single cell rna-seq data it actually
could mean many different things so to
really appreciate the different
approaches that have been more or less
established over the past decade or so
maybe a couple of decades now let's take
a look at some of these basic ideas and
technologies and try to understand how
do we capture this uh precision and this
you know dimension of single cell
so one of the first
ideas
is to
differentiate between cells right if we
are going to study something at the
single cell level we need to understand
how do we differentiate between many
thousands of cells that we potentially
have to sequence
and to do that one of the ideas is to
give them a barcode so if i could
generate a barcode for a type of cells
right i'm not generating a barcode for
every individual cell i'm just assigning
them to
maybe different tissues or different
batches or something like that
so here i have barcodes for example i
want to have a bunch of cells and i have
a tumor and i have a micro environment
right and i want to be able to
differentiate between them i can give
them a barcode
and those barcodes have to be
encapsulated
with the cell right and so if i kind of
take a droplet let's say an oil a
droplet of oil i can put a single cell
into that droplet and a barcode bead and
that barcode bead looks like this it
actually is a bead
that has these connected dna strings
attached to it
and once i prepare my data like this and
i keep them all inside the same bead now
i can sequence individual cells
so this is the basic idea right but now
let's take a look at three different
methods i think i have here
so the first method is called microwell
so the benefit of microwell is that you
actually end up with a plate very
similar to what you would do with
microarrays right you have a plate that
has these small
wells on the plate and you're hoping to
put in an individual cell within that
microwave
now this is a process that could be
optimal that could be optimized and you
can see in this case
this is that oil
[Music]
droplet and here is that little cell
right so that little cell right here
magnified over here you can include
additional phenotypic information
so essentially in this case you can make
different color
you know fluorescence and you can
potentially identify an additional
aspect just to give you a control right
but in many cases the limitation of this
technology is that you only have a
certain size right you cannot have
limitless well plates so you have a
limited size
and so
the number of cells is going to be quite
small right so if we're talking about
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
cells you're going to be limited by the
number of well you have and the number
of cells that you're going to
successfully place inside each
individual well
the second technique is called
microfluidics rna-seq and so
microfluidics really uh tries to
separate
uh everything again in ap so you have a
plate
and that plate is where you put
your cells inside this area right here
and then they start flowing
over here and as they flow through you
can see that you put in the cells they
start going in and they get trapped and
so these traps right here is where you
will end up having those individual
cells
and those cells again are going to be
well these are going to these are going
to be cells that you would hope to then
sequence at the end of the process
because then you can separate them
okay so this is that second
option right when we have microfluidics
the final one and and probably one of
the most successful ones is the droplet
single cell rna-seq data preparation and
the idea here is that you have a
continuous flow of drops
and
here you can see that the cell and the
hydrogen are incorporated into here and
as they flow you can monitor them
visually and you can separate the ones
that do have a cell in them or don't
have a cell in them so you have greater
control over this and you have here you
can see that
it kind of encapsulates them into this
oil bead and then you can flow through
and add the barcoding so this is really
a way to scale up and
automate this whole process
and so the idea is that you encapsulate
each individual cell inside a nanoliter
droplet together with the bead then you
can isolate the bead with the enzymes
that are required to construct the
library and each bead will contain that
unique barcode
that because this whole process is going
to be automated right and at the end you
have this ability to separate your reeds
into individual cells right and this is
the technology that is going to be used
most often today when you encounter
single cell data for example 10x
genomics is going to be utilizing
something like this
okay so the second part that we're going
to talk about is the basic processing of
such data so let's take a look at the
basic processing of such data and try to
understand what are some of the critical
steps that are required for us to
extract a meaningful matrix of
cell specific
expression of genes and then we'll think
about what are some of the challenges
associated with this process
so
i would separate this process into three
major steps
there's a process of
when you align the reads to the
reference genome basically that's the
idea
number two
you then normalize because you have so
many different cells so you want to
normalize the data
and once you normalize the data you then
want to assign them into particular
clusters right so the idea of clustering
will return to that later how to perform
clustering in a meaningful way
that is the overall kind of
review what are some of the issues that
we're trying to address at each one of
these stages
so let's first of all talk about this
first stage the stage of preparing the
reads aligning them and making sure that
we're only taking reads that are aligned
correctly to the reference
so as in any process of alignment
we will have fast queue files right so
in this case we already have fast files
associated with each individual cell
we then have to align these
reads to the reference genome and
generate a bam file right what is a bam
file a bam file is the same fast queue
but it now tells us the beginning and
the end of each read from the
perspective of the genome so you have
the starting position and the ending
position on the reference genome
now instead of using here
actual
individual reads
we now switch to umis right and umis are
adapters for each mrna so
umi helps us determine
how many mrna pieces are present in each
cell so it's like an alternative to the
read so instead of counting reads we
count umis in each cell
and that gives us a better sense of what
level or what abundance of mrna we
actually observe in more of a biological
sense than
just counting those reads right and so
here you can see
that each
read contains the barcode the umi
and so we count these umis
now we have thousands and thousands of
cells right so then the process to count
these umis
has to do with comparing cells to each
other right and and the problem
typically is that we don't have enough
rna mrna material in each cell and so
here we run into some challenges right
and the challenges are going to be to
assign those umis correctly and then to
have as much data as possible so that we
can actually take the high quality data
to make biological interpretations right
because if i for example want to
identify a cell type by a marker gene
but that gene doesn't have enough mrna
it's hard for me to distinguish between
low expression
and a missing data point right and so
that is one of the challenges that we're
going to run into
here at this stage of counting
and so an important part here is to
really
look only for cells that have a
sufficient number of humans that come
from gene coding mrna so typically here
we're going to be looking at just gene
expression not trans level expression so
an important part here is going to be to
fill out
only cells that have a sufficient number
of genes that i can assign an expression
level to them based on the overall
number of
my gene expression
uh can everyone see my screen
i see here on the chat if i can share
the desktop so i think everybody can see
my screen
okay
great
all right so okay so let's take a look
again at the overall process of getting
raw files into a pipeline and getting a
matrix at the end and let's think about
what we can do with that matrix after
this part
so first of all we need to identify
what essentially are we trying to get it
and we're trying to get a table
expression
so instead of samples we're going to
have genes so typically in a table of
expression you have genes
and and samples here we're going to have
a transpose table and we're going to
have cells and genes
and once we have only for cells that we
have sufficient data
for those specific
cells once we have a sufficient matrix
we want to check for artifacts right and
those artifacts are going to again help
us prepare a better table of expression
and that table of expression will be uh
you know as many cells are going to be
filled with numbers and not zeros and
that major challenge dependent on these
factors of data preparation
once we have that just like we do
involved rna-seq we're going to
normalize the data because we know that
the difference between mrna are not
always coming from biological
differences that could be coming from
these technical variability issues
and finally
we want to then understand difference
between groups of cells so let's now
take a look at how do we go to this
downstream analysis
basically we'll fall
into these three major challenges of
analysis
clustering annotation and analysis of a
trajectory and we'll talk about some use
cases where these approaches are going
to be most useful
so first of all clustering briefly i'll
give an overview and then we'll pause to
take some questions
so for clustering one of the major
challenges is going to be how do i
what do i call similarity right these
are going to be heterogeneous samples
and so i have a lot of variation just at
the level of expression i have a lot of
variation inside specific genes at the
level of expression and now when i try
to find differences or similarities
before i can do that because in such a
you know i have again tens of thousands
of cells here right so it's very
difficult to work with such complex data
before i do that i want to reduce the
dimensionality and we'll talk about two
methods t sne and umap to reduce the
dimensionality
and then once i do that i want to
perform a specific type of clustering so
depending on the method that i choose
for dimensionality reduction depending
on how many cells i have and how complex
the data is i can choose
different approaches for clustering
once i
determine that for example this is a
cluster and this is a cluster i need to
annotate them right and annotation means
to assign a cell
typically so when i want to assign a
cell type i want to select marker genes
that are coming from some database from
some publication and this is a major
challenge in single cell rna-seq is
appropriately assigning a cluster that
is based on a statistical analysis of my
data set to a particular of tissue cell
or condition in some cases right a cell
in a condition
and the final kind of analysis that you
can perform in some cases
is to try to determine exactly where in
a trajectory of development a particular
cell group is
now
in my sample right so
why is this an important thing and why
do we don't why do we not do this in
bulk rna-seq
cells are not static
cells are dynamic
and i have let's say a group of cells
let's say in a tumor right
cells are proliferating actively and
they are found in different stages of
proliferation so even though they are
cellular cells for example they could be
in different stages of differentiation
and i want to oftentimes find a process
that i could find individual cells that
have multiple representations now this
is going to be very appropriate for a
time series data set where i can take
for example
some progenitor cells and i can see
their differentiation over time but
sometimes it's also interesting to see a
process in a complex population of cells
and i know that these are all cells from
the same tissue but i know that they're
differentiating at different rates and
so i'll find some that are in the
beginning and and kind of toward later
stages
okay so let's pause here
and let me ask you if you have any
questions before we jump into some of
these data sets that we can leverage to
try to understand the differences
between different types of cells
all right so we have a question here for
human cells for annotation cell type or
classification is that where we may
utilize the human cell atlas
yes and we're going to look now at some
of these different uh you know
compositions or these atlases of cells
and try to see what are they trying to
achieve and how and how we can use them
so
you know here you need to think of
kind of several different challenges
first of all
as we know from collections of 100 000
human genomes thousand human genomes
hapmap tcga all of these collections
what did they reveal to us
every single one of these projects was
designed to map out the heterogeneity or
the variability of different populations
and we said that you know what let's
solve cancer we'll collect thousands of
samples of human cancer tissue and we'll
understand what does human cancer look
like
what we discovered is that we don't have
enough representation right and so the
idea that we can comprehensively map out
what's happening in biology is almost
impossible to imagine because by the
nature of biology is continuous
evolution and difference and uniqueness
right and so it's very difficult to map
out comprehensively everything that we
would like to identify so that's the
major challenge if you take the single
cell level the diversity increases many
folds and so that is where you're going
to find that challenge as well but yes
the idea is to try to map out as much as
possible and either from publications
where people biologically validated
these markers we can find marker genes
for different cells or different cell
types
and
you know in many cases we try to
approximate
okay the clustering step is done based
on which criteria
great so clustering in general looks at
similarity between
expression profiles
but in this case since we have many many
genes many many cells we first reduce
the dimensionality and we say let's
reduce the dimensionality and in that
hyperplane that we have created let us
find some distance metric and we'll look
at several different methods today and
we'll look at what goes into those
methods to then quantify something as
belonging to a particular cluster
okay um
rogan is asking how do we annotate any
novel cell population if we don't have
any database available i guess some de
novo algorithm pipeline to identify
novels so
yeah so a great point right so in in
many cases
right because we have limited annotation
we cannot assign a whole group of cells
right many many cells to any particular
type that is known
i mean the idea is that actually that is
the objective of single cell rna-seq is
to discover new things not just confirm
what we think we know and so here it's
going to be very important to have
clustering
that leads to discovery of markers right
and then we can biologically try to
validate and in fact we'll show today
we'll look at today at some of these
repositories and they also identify
novel types of cells as well and that's
an important discovery to make as well
okay we have another question
um okay liquid biopsy based single cell
sequencing for circulating tumor cells
for cervical cancer for that i'm looking
for single cell sequencing facility if
anyone knows okay so yeah there are many
single cell facilities so uh tons still
either someone here in the group or we
will be able to connect you with someone
uh hopefully in india i think okay so
maybe
you could point them to the right
direction
okay so if we don't have any more
questions let's take a look at some of
these references right where do we get
these um actual
gene sets
and markers uh and and what what is
found in there and what are these
efforts so first of all
let's look at one of these projects oh
sorry
one of these projects is going to be
a map of human tissue so this is the
publication um
let me just share
let me
get out of here real quick and i'll just
share the link to this publication for
those of you that are currently
working on this area i think this is
going to be a useful publication
okay so here
we have a publication about this effort
to try to
make a single cell type transcriptomics
map of human tissue so you can see that
this is
from july 2021 so a very recent article
and you can see here
[Music]
uh the human cell atlas dot org right
and this is something that
we can
actually look at let's try to understand
because we have this capability to
sequence uh you know individual cells uh
we would like to create a reference that
is a as comprehensive as possible of
human tissues and so this particular
effort
is trying to create an open access atlas
uh that will allow researchers to
explore the expression of human protein
coding genes in 192 individual cell type
clusters
and then an expression specificity
classification was performed to
determine the number of genes elevated
in each cell type allowing comparisons
with bulk transcriptomic data right so
there's a lot more data already that
exists on bulk rna-seq
and in this case we would like to take
these single cell data and increase the
kind of specificity or the detail of
this bulk
and so they took
you can see here both imaging
bulk rnaseq and single cell data to try
to dissect all these tissues into
individual types of cells that then we
could reference
and understand
specific genes that are elevated or down
regulated so let's actually take a look
at this um
this is uh
the place that you would go to
find the actual data and you can read
here a lot of the sources of the data
that they
used and also you can see some of the
examples of the data and the examples of
the data
are possible to view and visualize and
so that's what we'll do today what we'll
do today is
these collections because all of these
are going to be collections of data and
let's explore what does it actually look
like so if you go with me to this second
link
okay so i'll go
to this link
yes yeah so anyhow that's exactly
correct we're trying to build a
reference
so let's try to understand what this is
this is by the way um i i believe this
is um
uh
let's see
okay layout new map
okay this is
oligodendrocyte right you can actually
select many different
um
many different
types of tissues but let's just take a
look at here specifically what what can
we find so when we think of types of
cells right we typically say okay well
there's neuronal cells there is
uh you know oligodendrocytes there's
microglia macrophages etc right and you
can see here what in reality we find
right in reality
this type of analysis
helps us increase the dimension so for
example you can see oligo one
five two six four three so there's
six different types of oligo cells right
and you can see here
that you know if you actually select
they mix
a lot between themselves right these are
not clusters that are you know always
very very clearly defined i mean you can
see that all of them are right here but
they're also found right here so a lot
of these types of references
give us the strongest signal that we
have not all of them are so clearly
differentiated from each other right
some of them are but not all of them
okay so here for example
endothelial cells
um microglia right but but some of these
other types which are probably the
majority of the cells start to be more
spread out and more complex right so the
more we want to define these specific
cells we can group them into larger kind
of collections of different subtypes but
also within each
group this larger group will find more
and more specific trends and patterns
okay so this is healthy tissue okay so
remember this is
an attempt to map out all of the
different cell types
different
bulk rna data imaging data and you will
always see the differences in morphology
and kind of the
different phenotypic part of that data
as well but then you want to go deeper
and deeper and try to understand well
what are the differences within this you
know big collection of cells that we
call neurons right obviously there are
many different types of neurons
okay so the next thing that we want to
look at is look at some examples from
disease okay so
here we saw these are healthy tissues
now let's look at disease so this is a
collection of data
that was taken from
all of the you know possible data sets
that are available on tumors so
in cancer we would like to now
understand how different types of
cancers which we know are primarily
by tissue type right so when you have
breast cancer and lung cancer the
differences between those tumors are
going to be associated with the type of
cancer lung or breast
but now we would like to understand how
these cancer cells
differentiate within a particular
subtype
okay so this is again
something that you can find i'll post
the links here as well as well
this is a project by some chinese
university
uh where
they basically
re-annotated right they collected a lot
of metadata uh meta-analysis sorry of uh
data sets uh that came from uh geo from
ecga cetera right and they tried to
understand you know again what is the
relationship between what we know from
bulk and asic to single cell so again
let's take a look here at one such
example
so here we'll take
lung tumor micro environment and we'll
try to understand
here
what can we learn about you know a
condition like cancer which is a complex
condition that we can actually
try to interpret biologically so what
i'll do is i'll go to this link again on
your own free time you can explore all
kinds of other
types of data that are available here
and you'll find that you know a lot of
these are just collections of data sets
that others have published
okay so
here you will find a typical analysis
workflow and we will in our second
session today learn about the different
steps of analysis and how to actually
perform them but in my session i'm going
to ignore some of these basic things and
i'm going to move on to kind of like you
know what do we learn from these
collections
so again you will find here we have some
dimensionality reduction with t-sne and
umap
you can see that umap is typically going
to be a little bit better
making the separation greater between
the larger groups but actually if you
compare the two
you know it's obvious that both are
useful for example here i have a greater
resolution of this mixed cluster and
here this mix cluster is very condensed
together right
so if you scroll down
let's just take a look at this chart
right here and let's see so again this
is the tumor micro environment what is
the tumor micro environment the micro
environment is like the layer between
the tumor that kind of created its own
hyper growth aggressive this kind of
like uncontrollable
tumor that is hurting everything
and the normal tissue right in between
there's this area that we call the tumor
microenvironment typically it has a lot
of uh immune cells right so when
something like that happens the natural
reaction of the organism is to address
it by putting there the offensive right
and saying let's first of all quarantine
this whole place and then let's kill
them and so you see here uh t cells
uh you can see here macrophages and
other kinds of cells right and and
specifically you can see here if you
click right here that there's about
three percent of malignant cells right
why is this important well this is
important because a typical approach for
treating cancer is reducing the tumor
size through chemotherapy and then
trying to cut out surgically
whatever we can that makes that a
potential for new growth right and so
typically
that does not include all of the micro
environment because it's difficult the
micro
environment is integrated in a healthy
tissue it's difficult to separate it but
that is the problem the problem is that
you have three percent malignant cells
that are inside infiltrating the tumor
micro environment so if you think about
cancer and the stages of cancer it's all
about uh this proliferation and kind of
going beyond the boundary so containing
the two in a well-defined boundary is
stage one and as it goes beyond that
boundary that's when your stages
continue and eventually metastasis is
that they're way beyond right the actual
environment and so this is the problem
right here these malignant cells
now you can see here this is just counts
of cells
if you scroll down this is now
differential gene expression right so
now we would like to ask well what are
the differentially expressed genes
in these different clusters so these are
the different clusters
and let us try to compare them and
identify differences between the
clusters and here's what we have right
so these are gene uh gene names these
are types so these are the clusters that
we have so let's find here
those uh malignant cells right here you
see this is the malignant cells right so
this is
this cluster right here
and here we have a group of genes
that are unique
to this cluster right
so we can find these specific genes and
we can say okay whenever i look at lung
cancer let me look for these specific
genes and i will be able to find some
cells that are specific to this
malignant type so where do we find them
here here you can see i can find them
malignant right here malignant cells so
they are very different
and that is because if i could
look at the tissue and say here's the
group of malignant cells they're not
going to be grouped together they could
be spread out right but i can now
identify them and that is very important
okay so this is an example again we have
four cancer and you can take a look at
other examples as well
now let's take a look at another major
condition another major condition that
has been you know on the top of
everybody's mind
is sars cove two so here's a collection
again of all of the data sets that are
available for
um
covid19 and i'll paste a link to this
here as well
okay
here we can see how we are trying to map
out the uh develop
disease in different tissues right and
you start seeing these umaps that look
like this which is now a lot more
difficult to interpret right because
there's so much overlap here
but essentially what we can do is we do
a comparison like this
and in this comparison
we have
it's a single data set so again remember
that there's a lot of variability in the
data sets but here is the basic approach
let's take some covet 19 patients
some healthy patients and let's try to
count how many cells of different type
do i have
and so what's what stands out to you
in this comparison right here what
difference do you notice most between
these different
groups of samples
who would like to
take a look at that and suggest the
differences that you observe in this
chart so again
okay so julie is saying
endothelial lymphatic cells higher how
did she get to that idea right let's
take a look so first of all we're
looking at colors
inside each color box we have birth
cells
and the colors are actually annotated
down here below so here she's saying
endothelial lymphatic cells okay so this
is this purplish car
right here
is amplified in covid and almost doesn't
exist right maybe right here almost does
not exist
in healthy patients
you can also say the biggest difference
that i observe is this orange color that
is much less in covid compared to
healthy so here what is the orange i go
back over here alveolar right so what
kind of
what kind of
tissue is this this is lung tissue so
what are we seeing we're seeing that
covidon 19
is killing off right eliminating cells
that are alveolar
uh you can see here
expanding types of cells so for example
red right so here i can see an expansion
of red cells what are these red cells
these are natural killer t cells
okay so
we we kind of now can have a direct
biological interpretation well we know
that cobit replicates in alveoli
primarily
and then we see the natural killer t
cells are coming and attacking them
right and that is immediately clear from
this particular study and that's an
exciting thing to see because it really
confirms you know what we kind of know
intuitively
from reading these publications we see
where it's coming from and obviously
like julian noticed already a lot of
these
other types of cells have also been many
different as well right so now that
gives us an insight into what additional
questions could i ask right how could i
think about this and expand on this you
know basic level that i already know and
start asking more specific questions
okay so these are some collections just
examples you know there's also a mouse
uh cell atlas so a lot of work is done
on animal models right so there's a lot
of information about mice a lot of
information about human health tissues
some disease conditions as well you will
think the developmental aspect is very
interesting as well development of
different types of tissues
development of disease etc
let's take a look now at a publication
where we will see a connection between a
phenotype and
single cell level data
so just an example uh but this will help
us think about how people actually use
this kind of information in a practical
example so this is a project
you know it's not very new it's from
2017 and you have to remember that all
of these technologies to generate data
are expanding over time and you know
2020 we're 2022 so it's been now
five years and five years single cell
technologies have been advancing rapidly
but this is a great example of uh
of a kind of standard use case for
single cell data earlier on that was you
know integrating the parameters the
parameter of how an organ functions
and how we can observe the differences
at single cell level which is an
exciting and interesting way to think
about this
so this publication is called detecting
activated cell populations using single
cell rna-seq and it's talking about
neuronal circuits what are neuronal
circuits
neuronal circuits are essentially
connections between neurons in different
parts of the brain right so our brain is
a pretty big organ right here in the
head
that has many different components and
they have these very specific functions
but our brain
is not like a hand that works separately
and then a leg that work you know does
completing something else it kind of
works in an integrated way
and so here when we want to study a
behavior
they wanted to understand how neuronal
circuits
their mechanisms and pathways are
involved in behavioral response and are
really critical for our understanding of
anxiety related behaviors throughout so
here they took a mouse or mice and try
to understand how that happens so to do
that
they actually took
single cell data they sequence different
regions of the brain and because the
cells are spread out and they're
different they wanted to understand
specifically what is the functional
property of that cell
and they wanted to associate that with
behavior
so first of all let's look at these
circuits
so this is what
these circuits actually look like
um you can see here different parts of
the brain they kind of interact with
each other there are many different uh
things
to kind of understand here but in this
particular project they were trying to
understand how a stimulus
actually uh could be observed at this
basic biological level right how do we
kind of take this complex behavior
and map it out at this particular level
so they took
three different types of data
morphology
is illustrated here so morphology is how
these different cells look right what
what do they
look like under a microscope right
physiology and physiology here was
measured by
electric uh signals that could be
measured so it's the property of
electric signal being passed through
this complex structure right and you can
kind of see these patterns
and the final one is to connect it with
a molecular signature so what set what
genes actually function you know what
are amplified down regulated and how can
we connect those three things together
right a very interesting project
to really you know show that this
functionality is
regulated by particular genes particular
proteins that are being encoded in these
genes
so this is what they did they did a
single cell analysis of neurons
they did fluorescence and pseudo
hybridization or fish
and then they also did patch c and so
as a result you can see again a familiar
figure right so one of the major
challenges is let us collect all of the
cells and let us try to differentiate
between them
by type right and assigning those types
is a major challenge because we need to
have specific markers
and then we would like to understand
differences between these markers right
how do we connect the differences
between these markers with the actual um
with the actual uh phenotype and so let
me actually share here really quickly
the link
uh to this uh data or to this
publication so this is the link
okay
and uh to to really appreciate this uh
data set i think you know it's useful to
understand that
integration of multiple types of data is
ultimately one of the challenges and one
of the opportunities for these kinds of
projects so ultimately they did identify
as we saw um a specific
pattern right specific genes that are
amplified and they were able to just
like we saw here they were able to say
well this is how we can measure this at
the molecular level this is how we can
measure this at the phenotypic level
this is how we can measure this at the
physiological level and associate this
with behavior right so an exciting
finding so this is
just an example so again what what did i
show so far i showed uh three different
examples one
a collection of uh data to map out
normal variation
in different types of tissues and cells
in human and mouse
number two we looked at examples of
disease specific maps or atlases right
cancer covid and there are many others
and number three we looked at a
particular example of a study where they
tried to use this type of resolution at
the single cell level with asking a
practical biological and clinical in a
sense or psychological maybe question
anxiety and behavior
so are there any questions
okay so if there are no questions let us
take a look at as you saw in many of
these examples
we find uh these pictures right this is
a very standard picture we kind of look
at okay t snee
umap right we kind of tend to look at
this is the picture that defines single
cell right we all kind of see single
cell and we associate it with these
images so in fact it would seem like you
just put the data in
analyze with this method and you get a
result but the reality is much more
complex so here we'll take a look first
of all
let's take a look at this publication
that is called
the
of using t-sne
for
single cell transcriptomes okay so i'm
just gonna go i shared the link please
take a look at this link in your
chat box
okay so
it turns out
that these methods are not
straightforward right you can't just you
know take this method
right
and get the results and and everybody's
going to get the same result this is
something that requires an understanding
of the methodology
and the limitations of the data as well
okay so please let me know
uh once you've reached this
paper i think it's going to be very
useful
okay so here we have an example of the
same data set it's aesthetic data set
uh that is analyzed by different methods
[Music]
okay there we go okay look at look at
these
so your choice of
methods
makes a difference this is
mds or multi-dimensional scaling
pca principal component analysis
this is the default t-sne okay
this is when we change t-sne perplexity
and this is then uh different approaches
to pca right so we can
change parameters these are called hyper
parameters we can tune them and the
results will change in terms of
separation so let's first of all uh take
a look at
this example so this example what is
multi-dimensional scaling
multi-dimensional scaling basically
assumes
multi-dimensionality
we can use something like nmds
non-metric
dimensionality scaling or metric
dimensionality scaling but the basic
idea is that we have counts of these
umis and we want to identify distances
in either a metric
linear or a non-metric non-linear space
and here we can see that the differences
are going to be
dramatic so typically when you do a
dimensionality reduction approach you
then want to assign groups and that is
done through clustering right somebody
was asking well how is clustering
performed well typically let's take pca
now let's take a look at this example
because here we really see some outliers
primarily right and and not very good
clustering
here in pca
we see again this is synthetic data we
see very clear separation between
major groups and then we have
an assignment of clusters and it
basically tells us that there are three
clusters and these are homogeneous
clusters right so pca works by
linear dimensionality reduction and
linear euclidean distance so this is
assignment of clusters if we
take the same data set and we analyze it
with t sne we end up with many more
clusters right so here we have one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
ten clusters instead of three
right
so what do we see here we see
that the method that we choose will lead
to different results now if i'm a
biologist i will say okay
my method of analysis identified three
different groups
my question will be well what are these
groups how do i explain the differences
between these groups so i will measure
differential expression between these
two these two and these
but here i also start thinking okay well
this is many more differences now i have
to perform many more different analyses
and explore the differences but really
when i try to go from the standard
to interpretable results i have to make
decisions about parameters and i have to
make these decisions about parameters by
understanding the parameters not blindly
not because you know this is the
standard setting perplexity 30 random
initialization and equals 200 right
that's the standard parameter here i
have a change in parameters and you can
see how that affects what i will get now
another thing to remember is that t sne
works with already reduced data and
that's where this pca part comes in as
well i feed my t-sne with all revenues
data so typically a standard approach
would be a reduced dimensionality from
all dimensions to 50. so i'll have a pca
top 50 principal components and then i
run t-sne right and that also plays a
role in what my outcome will be so an
alternative to tease me that has
recently become
uh popular
is something that's called umap now i'm
sorry i'm going to run over time just a
little bit
okay excellent yeah so let's take a look
at
you know how do we understand these
parameters right that's your question
basically so let's look at this
interactive uh thing that will help us
understand some of these parameters so
this is i pasted a link
in the chat
and this is just an example
okay so again this is for t-sne
t-sne typically takes in the data from
pca already reduced typically number of
pcs is going to be your parameter
okay so here what you can do is you can
change the parameters
and then you can run
on a particular data set okay so let's
do the run just with the basic
parameters right now
and let's see what happens okay so this
is the result this is t sne
and you can move this around by the way
okay so this is t t-sne
and this is the 30 top principal
components
perplexity
which is the non-metric scale that we
use in
right
the distances that you see here are in
perplexity
the learning rate and the maximum
iterations because t-sneak can run
forever we need to limit it at some
point and so we limit it at 500.
did everyone run this first example
did everyone run this first example with
the basic parameters
okay after we run these base parameters
obviously we want to okay great so let's
try to change so again like i said a
typical change would be we would
increase the number of pcs to 50. so
let's increase this to 50.
okay and as we saw in the previous
example their perplexity was 100 so
let's change this to 100
okay so let's take a picture of this
that way we will remember
what this looks like
okay so just change those two parameters
and let's click on run
here remember that you also have this
option we're not going to touch this now
but let's just click on run
again i'm going to pull up
the original picture
okay so this is
what we did with
30
and
uh perplexity
um
of i think also 30.
okay so this is what we got now do you
think this has improved
or has this been
uh or did did it become worse what do
you think
okay worse so julian is saying it is
worse okay
why do we think it is worse what gives
you the impression that this is worse
julia
harder to distinguish cluster okay so
what if julia is saying
okay julian is saying that visually
right julia you're saying visually i can
see here the distance right the distance
between the clusters it's greater over
here
and it's less over here this is more
kind of together and that is why
i am saying that this is a worse choice
right this is a better choice and this
is the worst choice now surprisingly
there's actually a publication on this
that people kind of looked at how we
tend to interpret some of these analyses
and people determined that actually
that's true most people visually look at
a more appealing picture and they come
to the conclusion that this is better
now in reality you don't know that this
is better right what do you need to do
to make your decision what is better
right how would you you know choose that
appropriately
well there's actually an art to this
right so it does depend right you're
correct nicholas so it depends depends
on what depends on what the data is
right what is this data
so the data
how do we work in biological experiments
the data always has controls right and
so the first thing that i would like to
know is whether my controls are grouped
together right now in many clinical
settings i'm not going to have exact
controls but i'm going to have an idea
of these controls right and so it's it's
a lot more difficult than you would
imagine you know it looks like you look
at these publications and they all have
these nice t-snead pictures and they
kind of see you know this is a cluster
here this sequester here everything
seems to be you know so easy and perfect
in reality it is not you need to have
controls you need to understand your
data in many cases there are artifacts
and learning about the methods
themselves and playing around with these
kinds of parameters to understand again
this is a specific data set right this
is not just uh synthetic data anymore
we are now going to discover how these
parameters work and then you can apply
them in different situations differently
okay and that is something that you that
i want to be the outcome of today's
session is that you understand that you
know this is a promising technology
that is developing rapidly and we need
to understand the methods of analysis in
detail to be able to apply them
correctly
does the size of the data affect this
choice as well exactly yes and the size
of the data right what are we doing
right here with reducing the number of
pcs or choosing the number of pcs we are
changing dimensionality of our data so
we're reducing data okay so if if i
increase it even more
and i run it let's see what happens
this is what happens right so the more
data
the less clear becomes
right so the intuitive thing would be to
say that the
you know if my data is more simple
it is going to be
easier to separate but i'm reducing data
right i'm reducing the amount of data
and reducing the amount of information
and so it seems like if i reduce the
amount of information it's better for me
but is that the truth you know is that
always the case not always right in many
cases it's the opposite right the more
data includes the better results
so so this is something to think about
let's just quickly and know that we're
running over time but i'm going to
quickly uh uh go through another example
so in many cases you will find another
method
another method is called umap not t-sne
okay and this is going to be again
something to play with in your own free
time
uh i'm sorry it was just to one person
let's go to everyone in the meeting okay
so this is another example here to
understand umap now umap
is similar to t-sne
but t-sne runs into these limitations of
large and complex data sets and we have
to reduce it and so we are kind of
making the choice umap does not have
this kind of a limitation i'm going to
make this just a little bit bigger
okay and and here
uh the idea is similar you can
essentially play around with the number
of parameters using these
synthetic data sets uh so you can
kind of see what parameters uh
what kind of results right
and you can really try to understand
intuitively again
what are the specifics of these
parameters and how to try to you know
choose them
and here now you can also compare
between t-sne and umap and i think this
is you know a useful illustration to
kind of see uh how this works in a data
set that is a lot intuitive
than um the actual you know biological
data so before you jump into the
biological data sets play around with
this try to understand you know what
these parameters actually mean you have
a lot of many examples here and you will
see and and in the next session by the
way we'll go into more technical detail
so you understand the math and kind of
the coding principles because behind
some of these things but but this is
something that will help you understand
you know how uh your data kind of
theoretically uh should look like and
and what does it become in the end
okay so auditaio is asking
which parameters are available on the
tbio server so great question we will
get to that in just a few
more minutes okay
okay so again your understanding of
methods your understanding of the
parameters of these methods your
experience working with a lot of
examples is what builds your confidence
when you actually come to a real
practical challenge that you might see
in your own data set
um
okay yes more questions what are some of
the parameters that we can extract from
t-sne or um separately
from what i understand it's better to
run them both
exactly yes i would agree with that
assessment you want to run them both you
want to compare and contrast multiple
methods and then select something that
fits in with your controls
maybe go through several steps of
transformation and that is really why it
is useful to have easy to run
as opposed to being you know
stuck kind of dealing with the
complexity of running everything
independently which we will do today
together but you know i think still it's
beneficial to try and understand and
then be able to compare and contrast
exactly right
okay so we talked here about t-sne and
umap you know these traditional figures
that you know we always expect to find
in single-cell data and we understand
that parameters make a big difference
oftentimes counter intuitively right
counterintuitively means that
the simpler the data the clearer the
separation the more complex the data the
more challenging it is to find the
association between the data that we
expect and the data that we get in the
analysis results but that doesn't make
it wrong right that does not make it
wrong and we should kind of base our
assumptions not on what's intuitive like
visually this looks nicer instead we
should be looking for you know what do
we want to understand through this
analysis as we try to get to some
biological discovery or insights
okay so what are some standard tools
that you will be running across when you
are using
uh you know your single cell rna-seq
data what are some typical tools that
you're going to be using well
typically as i mentioned a lot of the
data is going to be coming from 10x
genomics
10x genomics have their own suite of
tools uh including cell ranger and this
loop browser
that allow you to explore you know
analyze and explore your single cell
rnac data and make sense of them and so
this is an example of screenshot you can
see it's 10x genomics
essentially the approach is going to be
similar right let's reduce the
dimensionality and let us look at either
all of your data or sample specific
so again remember that in each sample
you have thousands of cells and let's
try to categorize them by clustering now
the attempt to reduce the complexity of
the analysis to a more user-friendly
interface
is only as useful as the logic behind
your analysis your logic has to be solid
and then you can use
effectively
this particular interface is useful but
it can be misleading when you have to
adjust for
right this is going to jump directly
from here's your raw data here are your
you and my accounts here's your visual
like teeth in your umap what you're
missing is the ability to address the
technical issues before you get to this
step
okay now to really address the
complexity
of these types of data sets
typically people use two major packages
these major packages include sil-rat
which is a package that has been
evolving over the past several years
and now is in version four and that just
gives you a sense of how fast
this field evolves so if you remember
you know major algorithms for mapping
for example like bow tie you know we
only have bow tie one and bow tie two
right and that's it or you know you have
uh top hat you have top hat one top hat
two and then high set two right and this
is over the span of decades this in a
few years you already have uh number
four why why is that well because along
the way
uh people have discovered that there are
these issues these underlying artifacts
that we have to be able to discover and
address
new techniques allow us to select genes
that kind of make our analysis more uh
more reproducible
and more biologically interpretable and
so a lot of these kinds of changes are
going to be included here but this is
going to be available not only just for
rna-seq but also for other type of
single cell
data
okay so sale rat is a major package and
we'll we'll talk about this in a little
bit and another package is called
monocle right so in
the original uh
the original
attempt was to build a
uh
a specific method of analysis with
monocle
to just look at um pathways of
differentiation and cell differentiation
these
trajectories but today it evolved into a
whole suite of tools and these tools
include trajectories clustering and
differential expression and so uh these
are all important aspects of single cell
analysis
so what we will try to look at today is
the implementation of these different
methods
on the t-bioinfo server
where you can look at
the whole kind of step-by-step path
we're not going to run an actual
analysis we're just going to look at
this pipeline so that you understand
that it exists and later on when you
learn all these different methods you
will essentially learn how to reproduce
these kinds of visuals and then what
we'll do after that is we will go into a
collab notebook that you will see the
code behind some of these methods okay
so what is the uh t by owen for platform
the t-bone for platform for those of you
that are joining us uh for the first
time is essentially a big data analysis
platform that allows us to run complex
methods of analysis like we saw today
with a user-friendly interface that
hides the complexity of the algorithms
behind every single step
into a
logical color-coded and clear path from
raw data to structure data and then
gives you also access to tools for
annotation and statistical analysis as
well as machine learning
to actually conduct your full and raw to
insights right raw data to insights
and as you can see we recently added a
new section right here called single
cell analysis you can hover over each
section
and you will see here his width and as
expected we're going to be dealing with
umap and t-sne plots
so here we have two sections right the
first section is a section on
pre-processing what we described uh in
the previous uh kind of few slides
and then the new sections that we are
now adding are um advanced downstream
analyses including silrat uh using
bioconductor and then also spatial
single cell analysis and these sections
are going to be introduced during our
symposium at the end of this month march
31st and april 1st
and we have a scholar from the tower
bioinformatics research center who's
going to come and present some research
projects using some of these tools but
today we'll just do a very brief
overview
this platform is included with your
omics logic training
so you can gain access to this
and then we also have a research license
or a commercial license so you can
explore this but a lot of the methods to
learn you can do this for free and then
we'll show you how to actually run this
code so if you want to do a separate
penalty to do that as well so first of
all you have here the option to run
different types of data this is going to
be already process data right and we'll
talk later about what this data looks
like
we're going to skip the upload here and
we're just going to look at this
particular section down here
so i'm going to click on start
uh
in the start
essentially your data is going to come
in like three or four different files so
you're gonna have your gene matrix
you're gonna have your barcodes you're
going to have your metadata right so
you're going to have all of these
different files and you want to load
them in
check them for you know whatever data is
available so that everything is there
and once you have it you are then able
to process the individual data sets to
kind of make sense of them so the first
step is going to be with pre-processing
right we're going to do
qc
so as you probably see in many of these
papers there's the first step is to
really understand how many mitochondrial
uh and how many actual
mrnas do we have right that's the first
step of qc and you have here some
parameters that you can use to filter
out the bad cells right you want to
filter out the bad information that you
have
after that we talked about normalization
right so because you have different
types of cells different types of
tissues different maybe uh quality or
amount of mrna that was captured you
want to then normalize and you can do
that either with log normal data or with
uh sct so sct transformation includes
all these three steps right here so log
normalize fine variable features and
scale data
again here you can use these parameters
as well
after that we can if we expect this to
be cell cycle dependent we can use this
or typically we use dimensionality
reduction so pca again number of pcs we
just saw that parameter right there will
in jack straw
run only on variable features etc so we
can keep that as is
then we typically have again multiple
samples have some change right so you
have some overlap but it's not complete
and so to address that you can use
either harmony that's without pca or
sailrite anchor integration that means
that you identify genes that have
similar profiles and you use them as
anchors to adjust all of your data
okay and here you can use a limited
number of features to make it faster
after that we can perform clustering um
and then we can perform uh
dimensionality reduction umap
and t-sne
and compare them so we can actually
select both
and then and and by the way here you saw
that there are some uh options there as
well then you want to identify marker
genes right so again marker genes is
what will tell us you know what are
these cell types and we can then either
do this ourselves after we build this
kind of visualization we can either
manually annotate ourselves or we can
use these two methods
this method called cell decks which can
only work for human or mouse data
because it
works with the database of these human
and mouse cell types that are already
annotated
again you have here a few different
types of data
repositories that you can select from
okay and then
optional but possible you can run
differential expression either between
clusters or within clusters so you want
to understand okay in my
cluster of let's say immune cells you
know what are the different uh processes
that i have or how are my immune cells
different from let's say epithelial
cells right
so this is an overview of these tools
again i'm not going to expand too much
on this right now
what i what i will do um is i will pass
on
well before i do that are there any
other questions that i can answer before
we pass it on to dr raghav to talk about
how to code all of these independent
steps in r
okay if you have any questions feel free
to
paste them in the chat
i'll be happy to answer them
and again the t-balloon for platform
you can actually check out the section
right here
and uh you can
uh
you can
register for free
um and use the demo pipelines to learn
and and you also get an educational
subscription together with your learn
subscription uh for this platform
okay so dr raghav i'll pass it on to you
to talk about how to code these methods
in r
thank you thank you very much elia let
me find ways to share my screen and
get my video running i think my video is
not being recognized by zoom so yeah
okay let's um
you have to be content with my
photograph there okay let's find ways to
share my screen
can you see my screen
thank yeah very much okay excellent
okay
so hello and welcome everybody to the
second session of uh on this single cell
data analysis single cell
transcriptomics data analysis webinar
and this session is going to focus on
the downstream analysis of the single
data with packages like pseudo and yeah
with mostly with packages like uh cirret
and how we can implement them in
in a in our programming environment
using
shareable collab notebook so let us go
over some of the
already discussed
introductions that we had
so um
why is there a need for single cell iron
asic analysis and how is that different
from bulk rnaseq analysis so we already
found out that um
single cell transcriptomics profiles
or it quantifies mrnas present in each
and every single single cell and um this
uh this will this is
widely used in the single cell profiling
techniques like uh
um that will help us identify a
different cell types that are present in
the uh present in our sample and um
also understand the heterogeneity and
different categories or subcategories of
different population of cells that are
present in the
sample that we have based on depending
upon that or by analyzing the expression
variation between these cells so uh
unlike bulk cell rna seq profiling the
sequencing libraries there in the bulk
cell are generated for thousands and
thousands of cells and we have an
average gene expression that will ah
that comes out of
of all the cells so um
for some uh studies like i didn't
understanding the difference or general
difference between let us say tumor
cells or expression patterns between
tumor cells and normal cells
bulk rna
cell techniques are very helpful and
useful and are employed in those
in those methodologies but in order to
study and different tumor micro
environment for example or different
cell differentiation
patterns or different differentiation
patterns for a cell across the cell
cycles so
bulk rna
seek analysis might not be very helpful
and we have to resort to
single cell uh rnac analysis techniques
so
as yeah um
so this technique technology helps us to
measure the transcriptomic information
for a range of
thousands or even up to a lot of
millions of single cells in one single
experiment and by measuring these uh
transcriptomic information that are
specific to different cells we can
review the nature of heterogeneity or we
can understand um
the stochastic expression variability
that can be linked with the phenotypic
characteristics of the cell that is
quantified so um we already discussed
major differences between bulk single
cell rna seq methods to highlight few of
them
so uh
historically bulk cell uh rna-seq is a
major breakthrough that replaced
microarray technology and it has been
widely used to measure
average expression levels for each gene
across large populations or large
population of cells in a sample so these
methods are useful for comparative
transcriptomic analysis like as uh as i
already mentioned examples of the same
tissues from different species or
samples of the same tissues from
different
spot or different conditions so this is
also
helpful or
in quantifying gene expression
signatures for ensembles or in disease
studies where we are
where we will focus on understanding um
gene expression signatures for the
disease across different cells or
different
cells that exhibit the same disease
stage so but this method as we
understand is um is insufficient for
more um
revealing studies or
to understand the heterogeneity of the
system or to understand complex tissues
within for example say
brain
regions so for these purposes single
cell rna technique
technologies are very very helpful as
they measure the distribution of
expression levels for each gene across
the population of cells and
this uh technology as it says um as a
stage will allow us new biological or to
study
normal biological questions in which we
can ask cell specific or we can
investigate cell specific changes in the
transcripts of transcriptomes and to
identify different cell types and to
characterize um
for example gene regulatory networks
across the different cells and
and also to
study the stochasticity of the gene
expression pattern across different
cells so uh
major applications of single cell iron
ac technology includes as i mentioned
studying heterogeneity and to trace as
the evolutionary tracer cell
differentiation cycle across the time
and also to understand um yeah we
already discussed about this the
stochastic nature of the gene expression
pattern across different status of the
cell that we have so if we can generally
summarize the whole
single cell rna-seq quantification and
analysis processing
in general so
some of the key steps involves as uh
as it has already been discussed is to
extract
cells and to isolate these cells from
from the tissues in
with the technologies like um
drop c consumption etc and then
what follows is some of the steps that
share
share their library preparation
amplification sequencing and generation
of structured count matrix with the bulk
seeker bulk cell rna-seq technologies so
and then
and then we can perform a downstream
analysis um
to identify for different cell types or
to identify
novel biomarkers or normal markers that
will characterize different cell types
and also to construct cell trajectories
in the differentiation processes or in
the study of differentiation of the
cells etcetera so the analysis pipeline
while can be very broadly summarized as
you are already
known and gotten introduced to to
extends to the
extensive level of different
algorithms involved in this pipeline but
this is a very broad summarization
can be summarized as
upstream analysis that will constitute
until the generation of the count matrix
from the sequence read data and then
what follows that after can be termed as
a downstream analysis and some of the
major steps that in
that involved in this pipeline will
include
quality control uh which will filter
or which will select good quality cells
and
genes that express high
high variability or genes that are
expressed in
variance and
these uh selection or quality control
steps are very crucial for uh for the
clustering process and also for a
biomarker or marker
gene marker identification that will
characterize the cluster and hence help
us in
annotating these clusters to different
or specific cell types so
further down uh stream after the
generation of these um
count metrics we can
use the uh downstream analysis to for
example study the trajectory
to do or perform trajectory analysis and
to study
trajectories of
different cell differentiation and we
can also perform differential gene
expression of marker genes across the
cell types or across different clusters
and also we can uh yeah do our perform
novel identify novel marker genes that
will characterize these cell types using
uh packages like shurit and
yeah
mainly using packages like uh surety
so uh as we
we already found out the uh upstream
analysis can be performed in in tbio
info server by setting up a pipeline
that is similar to this where
they that include preprocessing mapping
and
assigning of the reeds and identifying
different cells and and then
quantification of the
gene expression
levels for different cells so uh for a
typical pipeline like this which will
take in the first q files and then
produce
structured count matrix data the output
will look like or the output that is
generated
will have
the count matrix
table
that can be subjected to further
downstream analysis so if we download
this count matrix table and we can open
it up and
this is what we see a typical account
matrix
will look like this where we have
columns of
the columns of the tables are the cells
as represented by the barcodes
in their header and and the rows are
transcript ids
as represented by their ensemble id
names and what we have in them is the
expression level for this gene
expression g for this particular
transcript across our um
for specific cells or different cells
that we have and um
one striking difference that you see
for example when you compare a count
matrix table to
general gene expression table of bulk
cell ironic analysis is the number of
zeros that we have
in the count matrix table and that
yeah
this will quantify or qualify this will
qualify as a
sparse data or sparse table so which for
which we have to um include um
imputation methods and further methods
in which we can
from which we can make use of this first
data and and perform uh further analysis
so uh to do this or
hence um
since this table is is sparse and it
includes lots of zeros and there is a
general asymmetry in the
expression level of these genes across
different cells then
many of the analysis techniques that we
are going to
use will be non-parametric and
non-linear
technologies are non-linear uh
algorithms so yeah
so from these we can actually
identify or we can use a database of
known molecular markers or known
molecular markers that are genes
um
and that will
that that will associate these genes to
specific cell types and can be uh and
can be used to annotate the cells are
present in the count matrix or the cells
that we observe in the
count matrix and generate a table that
looks like this
so ah from here with the help of
non-linear
dimensionality uh reduction techniques
like tc umap
we can visualize the segregation pattern
or we can visualize distinct clusters of
cells uh that are present in our um
in our or that that the data
in our count matrix describes so um
these distinct clusters that we can
identify uh based on uh based on the
segregation pattern of cells
as exhibited in the gene expression
table we can identify uh cell
specific cell types or specific clusters
that will
that can be annotated by um two cell
types based on the
marker genes that we have uh used so far
so this is a very a very broad uh
step uh or overview of how downstream
analysis can be helpful in and
understanding the cell types let us go
over these steps one by one in in detail
and what are the different
analysis processes that we can subject
our count matrix to and what we can
learn
from these
analysis processes and then we will go
to a
practical demonstration of how to
perform this in
our environment so for this data we will
make use of um
we will make use of the
p b and c or peripheral blood mono
mononuclear cells data
data set that is freely available from
10x genomics in this link so all you
need is to
sign up or all you need is to mention
your written
name and associated institutes or
associated email address and then
download this data it is freely
available and it is yeah
and
we can make use or we can use this for
our further analysis or downstream
analysis
in the google collapse network so um
when or while downloading this data the
10x genomics actually provides us a
summary of various statistics that are
that we can observe from this pbmc data
and also it can help us to compare
and we can and also it can help us to
compare what are the recommended
statistics uh and based on that we can
identify or we can immediately notice
that the data that we currently have
satisfies all the recommended statistics
or required recommended statistics for
performing a reliable downstream
analysis
with the data that we have
so uh
some of some of the key potential
problems that we have to uh keep in mind
that we have to keep in mind before uh
proceeding further uh is
these are those general potential
problems that are associated with the
single cell rna analysis
methods so for example the amplification
efficiency and hence because of that the
quantifiable or detectable gene
expression levels are typically very low
or less so this low amplification if the
efficiency will actually place the
number of genes or the transcripts per
cell very close to um
very close to a technical noise level or
very close to a level which can be
characterized or which can be defined as
technical variations so we have to find
out or we have to leave out those
transcripts which exhibit
expression levels on the on this side of
the ah
curve so we are going to consider only
for those uh transcripts which which for
which we have ah very high um
expression uh variation or amplification
efficiency
so um
we further have other technical issues
like
gene dropouts we can have
missing cells from the droplets or we
can have ruptured cells or we can have
a fused droplets where more than one uh
cell can can be present in um
present in one droplet and all these can
potentially complicate the analysis
pipeline and hence you will see
we have to perform multiple rounds of
quality control or multiple rounds of
threshold setting or identifying
threshold or efficiently
filtering problematic data from the
downstream analysis to uh make some
sense of this
data or to
understand and identify
patterns
that can be reliably
related to the phenotype or biological
phenotype that we have for the samples
for the sample understand
so uh
keeping this in mind once we have the
count matrix and we can perform this
assured base analysis in in the um in
the talbot bioinfo platform pipeline
also so some of the major steps has
already been gone over by elia include
um
specifically include to
quality control to perform quality
control and to select
or to leave out bad quality cells or to
select only good quality cells for each
sample and to normalize the data for
each sample to correct for the batch
effects and to correct for other
problematic variations in the data and
we
further we have to
reduce the dimensions or not reduce the
dimension we can say select the specific
dimensions or number of features based
on that
very high variability that it can
that it can demand that that it can
represent or that we can
show
and then we have to perform integration
or we have to
[Music]
use non-linear techniques like disney
and umap to visualize the
sample segregation or cell type
clustering or cell type separation in
the
non-linear dimensions or in the
represented or reduced dimensions and
then to do this we have to
perform proper scaling of the data and
we have to perform centering of the data
because without centering and scaling we
cannot perform pca or any dimensionality
reduction techniques and then
we can further use
batch effects or remove batch effects
using harmony methods or
fast dominant letters then
we can
select key principle components
and then
by selecting key principle components we
can also identify
those specific genes which contribute
most to the
most of the significant principle
components that that will be or that
will be employed in non-linear
dimensional detection techniques like
disney and umap and then what follows is
after this visualization we have to
perform clustering and in clustering
options we will
identify and find different clusters
and
the goal in clustering as as you had
already been
introduced to is to identify or is to um
place similar cells together in a very
low dimensional space
what happens suddenly okay yeah so and
then we can after identifying or after
characterizing the
sample segregation um
based on different clusters that we can
visualize or that we can identify in our
map then we have to assign these
clusters to cell types or annotate these
clusters ah to different cell types
based on the marker genes that are
different or the one that qualify for um
as a significant gene that can
differentiate between different clusters
and then once we have performed this
annotation we can further
parallelly perform a differential gene
expression or differentially expressed
genes identification of differentially
expressed genes between clusters or
between cell types in our ah downstream
analysis so all these methods we can
perform in in the in a pipeline or also
we can perform in
using rs environment by installing a
package or instead of one package called
seward
which has the ability to perform all of
these analysis in the
using
um
very highly sophisticated
visualization techniques we will go over
that and let's see um
yeah so
one of the important steps as as it has
been discussed multiple times is to
remove low quality samples or is to
mention a threshold based on which the
low quality samples are removed so how
does it how is it done so it is usually
done by ah by understanding or by
plotting the number of genes across ah
different samples and then um then
this can help us in understanding cell
doublets or self multiplets
which will exhibit an apparently high
gene count so most of the gene counts
here for this
for the samples are centered around this
1000 to 2000 range so whenever we have
samples that have really very high
number of genes then we can
use a threshold
based on which for example let's say if
i use a threshold of 2000 then
that 2000 threshold we can identify
from these
quality control violin plots
so
visualization so this will be different
for different data so for data this data
we can use a cutoff of like say 2000
which will cover most of the cells ah
most of the samples and most of the
genes above which we we may suspect that
we have uh different
problems or we have low quality cells ah
that we do not want to consider for our
analysis so the percentage of
mitochondrial genes is also very good
here it is on the very lower side so
what will happen is um
whenever we have cells that are ruptured
and their mrna mrna molecules that
escape from the cells
from the cell then we will we will have
the only available uh genes are from the
mitochondrial counterparts or
mitochondria so
for those cells we will have very high
percentage of mitochondrial genes um and
hence we can understand or we can
identify uh or we can
we can find a threshold based on which
we will want to filter out
the percentage of mitochondrial genes
for which we suspect um
the the cells may have been ruptured or
the cells may have been dead or of low
quality but this also you have to keep
in mind that this is not the case for
most of the
this is not the case for all the
biological
situation
where um for example when you have
yeah
um
hello yeah so for example when you have
um
when you have uh
for example
specific biological systems where we
have
when you study cardiomyocytes or
different cell types where
those cell types generally exhibit a
very high
level of mitochondrial reads or very
high percentage of mitochondrial rates
then we have to understand the biology
of our samples and then ah take this or
identify the threshold based on which
the
mitochondrial genes are going
filtered out and then as we already had
discussed in this
graph we have to identify only those
genes that exhibit most variation
because when you
when you standardize a variation in the
genes across average
average expressions then ah
we should not be left with the genes
that have very least amount of variation
across the cell types and that will
potentially impair our identification or
empower our
cluster
or
quantification of cluster or empower our
biomarker or marker genes identification
across different clusters or different
gene types so for this we will have to
um ensure that
above a standard varia variance level
above which
only above which the genes that exhibit
these variance level across the
different cell types are considered for
further downstream analysis this is yeah
this will reduce a large number of
features or cells that features or genes
that we have for example
in this case in this example we we can
see that uh
we are going to filter out something
around 4000 genes and we are going to
use only
genes that ex that are
that exhibit
most variants or exhibit most variants
variance
in account and that that count will be
around 2000 so
in other way uh when we plot this
standard variance plot then we are going
to use only top 2000
most variant genes for our further
downstream analysis that is going to
help us quantify or that's going to help
us characterize these clusters and
yeah that's going to help us
characterize these clusters and annotate
these samples so um
yeah so where are we can you see my
screen i cannot see my screen
yes now now it's now it's up there okay
so once we have filtered out noisy
features or once we have entered our
genes then we can continue to visualize
the presence of global structure or
global pattern in our data by performing
clustering and to study variability
across these clusters or across the
differential types so we perform
clustering mainly to determine for
example a subset of genes that can
characterize different cell types or we
can
determine the variability and difference
in the expression pattern across
different cell types
based on our data so this is this
clustering will be very efficient and
all these processes will be efficient
only when we have um filtered out lot of
noise from our data and we have
subsetted or we have selected only very
few top quality genes or features or top
quality cells to
focus our downstream analysis to
so to understand the number of
informative clusters we might that we
might find in our data we can make use
of something called as elbow plot where
their variants expressed or explained by
components and the number of clusters
can be
plotted and and then the goal is to
identify and the change in the curve
pattern or change in the curve and where
after this specific point there is no
meaningful
separation can be achieved by dividing
the available data or available
distribution into different clusters so
based on this we can make a decision
that ah yeah maybe this is around
10 or 11 i think yeah and we can
use
11 as a cut off or 11 as a goal to
identify different clusters in our
cluster map or in our
dimensional reduction techniques
so
yeah
so we already discussed a lot about
non-linear dimensionality reduction
techniques like t-sne so this is a
clustering result of t-sniff plot
visualization for the data for the
for the data that we have and
and the number of clusters that we
identify comes from this elbow plot so
ah we we want to identify 11 different
clusters that might not be
all the 11 clusters may not be um
relevant in this case so this could be
an iterative process so here we want to
identify 11 different clusters and then
the data is good so uh we can uh
actually see
the presence of most of these clusters
as separate entity and not as um yeah
not as distinct or not as
scattered uh points
so uh in addition to t sne we also got
introduced to umap and other uh
nonlinear based
dimensional reduction techniques which
will in essence use the top principle
components to visualize these patterns
right so that is what
we will use uh to speed up this process
of
getting or identifying
these clusters in using a non-linear
based or non-linear differential
technique so let's let me quickly
yeah
yes
so what do we have next then next what
do we have is uh to understand uh the
gene expression or different marker gene
expression pattern that are specific to
uh each cluster so this can help us
annotate the clusters based on the cell
types
and ah and we and further we can also
understand or we can also perform a
differential gene expression analysis
for ah for the
marker genes across different clusters
or across different uh cell types so
this is this is a very
very poor and broad graph and i will
show you another
graph which will
which will be a which will take only a
couple of examples that will be very
clear
so
more useful representation like a dot
plots can be helpful
can also be helpful in understanding
marker genes that are specific to
different uh
that are specific to different um
clusters or identity here
and and
when you have larger data sets where we
have a lot of cells and and
box plot uh kind of our violent plot
kind of representation can confuse or
can can be insufficient in identifying
or in in comparing the patterns of these
marker genes across different clusters
so for those cases it is recommended to
perform dot plots where
the
the plot naturally shields the noise
that are caused by very low express
genes or dropout genes so uh when you
have a lot of cells for example a lot of
different cells in this case
a dot plot is more
informative and useful than performing
or done
visualizing the gene expression pattern
across different
cell types so this we have only 11
clusters so we have only 11 but when you
have a lot of different clusters then
the complexity keeps on increasing
so this is uh annotating based on the
marker genes that we have identified so
first we have to identify different
clusters and then we have to identify
the marker genes that characterizes
these clusters
and
are not common to other clusters and
then based on these marker genes that
will be
that are
specific to specific clusters we can
identify um
the cell types uh that are
and identify the cell types and then
annotate these clusters with the cell
type so ah this can be performed this
can only be performed after identifying
the marker genes and
once we have identified the marker genes
we can
use the annotation and label our
clusters based on the annotation that we
have identified on that rule that will
be helpful in understanding the
segregations
or segregation of these different cell
types in our
based on the gene expression pattern
that we have
so uh yeah we can also use um
heat map based method which is
for which
the differential expression of these
markers across different cell types are
actually calculated and the differential
expression analysis is is very similar
to the method that that
that uses hr for bulk basic analysis so
when we when we use this
when we use this heat map
mode to visualize the most
differentially expressed genes we can
potentially identify novel biomarker
genes or novel markup genes
in addition to the already existing
marker genes like here uh or we can also
observe patterns uh
for identifying additional cell types
based on the
gene expression data or pattern that we
have here for example um this does not
that this is a very high quality data
set and this doesn't
give out any additional uh
cell type or cell patterns but yeah when
you see a marker difference between or
within one cluster then that those are
considered as considered as hints for
the presence of more than one type of
cells or more than one type of um yeah
yeah more than one type of cells in that
specific cluster itself so um
yeah as i mentioned uh if i zoom into or
if i select only a couple of genes
for the violin plot representation then
we can easily identify
for identifying
the expression patterns that are
that are high for these
for which the expression patterns for
these specific genes
for different clusters and then we can
say that okay
for cluster 10 ccl4 is a marker gene and
similarly for cluster 11
this gene is a marker gene so
so when we have a similar expression
pattern for the genes across different
clusters so obviously they cannot be
employed as smarter genes also we can
use from this
information we can use some additional
analysis of marker genes
identification for different clusters
then
so this is so far we have been dealing
or discussing with
samples or single cell rna
quantification methods
that is measured for sample for one
condition so we can also have samples
that are um for which single cell data
is recorded for multiple different
conditions so when we have um
such sample or we can have a single cell
rna data measured for samples for
multiple different time points and we
have then we can perform um
or perform a differential gene
expression
analysis across different conditions and
then identify or we can
trace the level of expression across
this different condition and then
relate that to the
sample stage that we have
so um yes so this is also very very
useful visualization where for example
in addition to what we see here
when we use only
selective
marker marker genes and then
visualize the presence of those marker
genes to
characterize or being
character characteristics of different
clusters then we can say that
we can see
their
pattern or their expression pattern as
observed in different clusters but this
is also very useful
mode of visualization for
ah for the tsn clusters or for the you
maps different uh non-linear dimensional
p reduction technique clusters and
identification of math variants so we
will do all these we will perform all
this in the google collab notebook so i
can
actually stop here uh to ask for
some questions if you have until sorry
if you have uh
for the session until now before
going to um
to a demo mode please let me know if you
have any questions of any queries
and and then i can proceed to the demo
mode
do you have any questions
or is everything clear
maybe with the demo demonstration you
will have much more
freedom and have a lot more clarity
shall we proceed
i think we can yeah
yeah okay i think we can proceed with
the demonstration
i will stop share and share my google
collab
notebook
share my screen
yeah please yeah please
please confirm that you can see my
screen or view my screen
yes so we can see us okay perfect thank
you very much
yes so um
we are going to do everything and also
we can do a much more in the c red
libraries and packages in
the using
this collab or also you can install the
same in your
rstudio which is that is recommended
because this can take a lot of time
to perform so um you have to if you
don't have the sewerage package you have
to install the server package and this
is optional you don't have to install
the secret data but yeah other
packages will include ggpro 2 for
visualization and patchwork for other
variants identification dplyr for
general ease of
visualizing and
table and other data so let me quickly
ask how many of you
have a decent experience with r and r
studio
recent programming experience with r r
studio
please yeah
please
yes or
i
include something in the chat window so
that i can go through
yes excellent so that will help a lot
because yeah so um
if you do not have a lot of experience
in in using r as an analysis platform
for your downstream analysis then we
have a
lot of introductory courses in r which
will help you in a step-by-step manner
how to load data for example and how to
use different libraries to visualize
etcetera etcetera that will be very
handy here but for this
specific analysis we are going to
limit ourselves to loading cira and
other packages and most of the ah
and most of the uh
functions and everything is very well
demonstrated or very well developed in
seared package and they have an
excellent
help
and have an ex they have an excellent
help site which can be uh which can be
used or which can be utilized for
further knowledge so let's let's go over
this and that
let's load up the libraries
just loading the library and for the
data that we have uh this data is there
as i mentioned pbmc
3k data and
where they have around
2700 single cells and
13 000 or 14 000 genes
for cells or not versus for these for
these different features so if you go to
this specific
link
so that link is going to uh okay since i
have already down
since i have already
logged in this is actually giving me
to help asking me to download this but
usually when you click this link or when
you go to this link it will ask you to
fill out what's your name what's your
email address etc after which after
which you can download the data and then
after downloading this data
you can unzip and then we will find
let me share everything
yes
i think you can see all my screen so
after unloading this then you will
generally find
these three
files can you see my screen i think you
can see my speaker so the matrix dot mtx
is a count matrix or the output of the
count matrix that you will
generate when you perform the upstream
analysis and barcodes are the barcodes
to identify different cell types and
genes are the different genes that are
associated with the ensemble
id that we have this will be very
helpful i will tell you how in the
downstream analysis so these three are
the files and
the barcode and matrix files are
absolutely necessary for performing
downstream analysis if you don't have
genes
then we might be hindered in identifying
the identifying with genes
associated with ensemble ids but it's
not very difficult to relate or it's not
very difficult to get a list of genes
that are associated with ensemble ids
that we have so it's easy to make these
so these are the three files that you
want to upload where do you want to
upload in this collab when you get hold
of this collab so you want to go here
and then open up the folder
and if you see a sample or any other
content or any other folder location you
have to go to the root folder
that can be let's for example let's say
if i'm inside this
how to open this
okay
yeah
if i'm inside this then i can press
dot dot back and then go back to this
root mode and then i see here i have
uploaded these files directly here using
this specific
upload to session storage
so this is where you will tell
the code to find the input data which
will be absolutely necessary for our
document analysis let's go
and then
this is where i'm telling the data where
to find
the read 10x data where to find the
readings
[Music]
yes
thank you very much so um
we have to create something like a
secret object which will
take these count metrics and then take
this barcode and take these genes and
then combine everything together and
then
and then it will
create a data frame like object that can
be employed for further student based
analysis so let's run this this is very
simple and when you uh use this data for
um
for visualization this this is what it
looks like we can let's open up a new
one you can say
i hope this will still work
yes so if you see the dimension of this
cigarette object or data frame that we
have so it has
thirteen thousand seven hundred and
fourteen features or thirteen thousand
seven hundred jeans across two thousand
seven hundred cells uh
uh yeah um that we
have yet so we can
for example display a few g's and then
see what what are their expression
patterns here or we can also use
head
and then
see that is what you have here you have
a data frame of
number of counts we have number of
features in this one but if we use
specific genes then we can identify or
we can see
their expression pattern across the
different cell types and
here is the example of the sparseness of
the matrix that we
observe or that we
see
for example this is in the counts yeah
if you go to instead of head
if you use
let's say
10
to
3.
okay okay zero variable features why is
that so
because it's the other way around
okay
i think yeah i think i have to do some
dot data
yes so this is what i wanted you to want
to do to see
so you have a lot of sparseness in these
uh
in these um
[Music]
in this data
let's see yeah so generally you have lot
of sparseness in this data where
you have
expression patterns or expression levels
only populating a few of the
cell types and not all the cell types
are
with the data so
we can use different heads and different
different
display
options to
peek at the data and then
we have to quickly uh go to quality
control metrics one of the quality
control metrics that i i mentioned is to
identify the mitochondrial genes or
mitochondriology percentage genes and
then get rid of those mitochondrial
genes so how we can do that we can
actually use the
use the grep command or we can use the
pattern with which all the mitochondrial
genes are actually
are actually encoded are the have us
have their g names that starts with
uppercase m and uppercase t hyphens
we can use this pattern to match
for their presence in the feature set
and then we can get rid of those
mitochondrial genes and that's it yeah
so uh when we uh yeah
that can be
done and first we
and then uh we can take these uh
match this
pattern and then
create a
create another column that is going to
count or that is going to
quantify the amount of
mitochondrial dna or mitochondrial dna
percentage present in each and every
cell type so this is the input file that
we will use for our violin plot which
will tell you uh whether the percentage
of mitochondrial data mitochondria gene
or the percentage of different
dna for um
for the samples or unique umi's for the
samples how how many different ones that
we have and then we can set our
threshold based on it so
so when we plot the violin plot we will
know what we want to plot here
then we can use this to identify it so i
encourage you to
go to that website or i can also give
you a link of another dataset so you can
perform the same analysis for a
different data set
so
this is this is a difference to show you
how
um how for example
normal genes ah and their expression
patterns uh expression level uh or count
level vary uh between uh normal genes
and also between uh mitochondrial uh
so when we have
so um
you can you can uh simply plot a scatter
plot between
number of counts of the gene gene counts
versus percentage of the mitochondrial
dna and then
we can
make a scatter plot between the
expression counts and the number of
features that we have and yeah
this can also help us
tell
that the percentage of mitochondrial
genes
present in our
data so
this will also help us
visualize the
relationship between the amount of
mitochondrial genes present in our data
so
for example here yeah so this is where
we are going to uh
employ the um
filtering or this is going to apply the
quality control filtering that we will
identify uh from these box plots
from this box box so
we can say we want to have the number of
features of rna
should be greater than 200 and which
should be lesser than 2500
and
our percentage of mitochondrial
dna should be less than 5 percentage so
we don't want a lot of zeros in here so
we won't have 200 to 2500 and that's a
block that we are employing for um
from from this
while in plot
explorative analysis so this is where
we are rewriting our data set by
subsetting the data set of this and
let's see
if i
do the dimension how much have we
reduced
so um yeah we have not reduced a lot
when we go up uh
i think okay
yeah
uh
from 2700 samples we have uh
filtered out something around 400
samples or only 78 samples so we have a
very high quality sample and that that
we also can visualize from this data
where we don't have lot of dots
above the 2500 under the upper region of
these plots which is representative or
which is
what you will
observe for
data that is not very good
so after this so we have what is it yeah
so we have uh perform this filtering and
then after this filtering we have to
perform something like normalization and
so that we can
use
visualization technique and
dimensionality direction methods to our
data and we also can
compare
expression
measurements across different samples
and
in a normalized scale so we perform
normalization
and we put a scale factor of one
thousand or ten thousand sorry and then
uh we will actually use uh
this uh
variance stabilization
technique which is the same method used
in something like ajar and desect 2
analysis to understand
most variable
features this is what we spoke about in
the in identifying most variable
genes so this this actually tells us if
you can see here
you can see that it's 13 000 features
that we have
and after performing this
and
yeah after performing this let's see
let's see three
yes so uh
okay
yeah so we have only okay but something
is
missing
yeah we are subsetting these two number
of features that is greater than yeah
that is for
greater than
uh 2000 variable count yeah so
non-variable count is 30 yeah something
is missing if you see here let me come
back to this later and i address this
what happens here
so um so after this we will use this uh
variable plot to uh
uh plot which are the genes that we are
which are the um
variables or variable genes that we are
actually counting to
um
further analysis so this is this is some
of the top
genes with their
with their annotation present here and
we can now perform scaling of the data
we have normalized the data and we have
identified top variable genes in the
data then we can perform a scaling of
the data and then
do a pca on the data to identify
top genes that are going to contribute
to defining
the different principle components
for our data so let's give yeah let's
use scale data function to scale it
and then we will run pca to do it a lot
of these functions are slightly
different from
what you are going to see
i will share the notebook yes i will
share the notebook yes
let me
okay this is the notebook that you can
go through make a copy of this and
yeah
and
go through uh
sorry let me yeah my yeah so um after
performing pca then we have to uh decide
upon number of components that we want
to use for our uh non-linear
dimensionality reduction uh methods and
techniques so for that we will uh
quickly um
for example print out
different genes that are very
that are specific or that are
characterized that characterizes uh the
principal components p one and p two so
these are these are called dimension
loadings and if you see the
loading
plot in in normal pca where you will
have different
features that are that will characterize
different principal components and how
how they are closely related to each
other so this is a different this is a
this is one another
visualization pattern for the
different dimension loadings then
we have for these two dimensions we have
these are the genes that are that
contribute to most two
to characterization of the pc1 and pc2
so finally we plot
the principle called we brought the plot
our data
um
using the principal components that we
have calculated
and
even with the principle components that
we can see our data exhibit
some sort of structure is very broadly
maybe i can say four clusters identified
but this is where we stop with the
linear dimensionality reduction
technique or representation like pca
you can make
even view accesses plot we can make uh
yeah i think you can make a copy of this
let's see
okay
get link
copy link
yeah restricted to only open with okay
not like that
anyone with the link
yeah viewer done okay anyone with the
link you can open this uh
colab yes so um
so we we do
basically we don't have a lot of very
many different clusters and we don't
have a method to identify clusters from
pca so for that we have to resort to uh
non-dimensional transaction
disney and umap and based on pca maybe
we can do uh
something like dimensional
different heat maps for that
for these
pc according to the dimension scores and
this this will actually help us
decide upon the number of uh
principle components that will that we
can employ forever for the non-linear ah
dimensional interaction techniques
because that uses the top 15 or top 20
pc principle components that we are
going to mention now that we can we have
the option of mentioning so here if you
see that
the heat map after something around
let's say
pc8 of eight components actually fizzes
out and there is no
not much identifiable pattern
left so we can reduce our
there is a number of principal
components to be used and analyzed to
eight for the
new map on this one so this is as as we
already saw jack straw is a very useful
method to
identify
[Music]
the principal components that will
for example that will qualify
based on their p value
to differentiate between the different
cell types are differentiated between
two to be contributing to the variance
that is observed in the original data so
this is a jack straw plot but mind you
this is going to take long time to
compute so that's why i have already
computed so if you start this this will
for example in my computer for this
connection it took two minutes but it's
it can very well take i've had um
sessions where it took something like 10
minutes to calculate so
so for this for the jack straw plot you
see you observe this
cut-off value here and that determines
the different principal components that
we can employ essentially for further ah
dimensionality reduction
techniques ah or
disney and umap
so we see that
if this
10 to 12
pca is not very
visible here or we can see it here
and the normal p value cut off 0.05 can
be employed here which will qualify
first 13 principal components or 0.005
can be employed
or even higher cut off can be employed
and we can see that first 12 components
has a very high
or very low p value very good p value
score so we can we based base our
collection based on this observation
here also we can do the same using the
elbow plot the elbow plot as
can show you show you the
deviation then one might um
standard deviation then one might
relate to the number of principal
components that we have and
this yeah this tells that we we could
have actually have had good results by
stopping at eight or nine
principle components and then to enable
clusters then we have to
find
neighbors and for this we can employ
for example umap and
yeah before that we can find clusters
based on the um uh based on the
scores or based on the um
that's
course that
that we have computed uh from our pc map
principle component map
and
from this course first we have to
identify the nearest neighbors and
there are multiple different ways of
clustering and this is one of the best
way uh identifying nearest neighbor
method is the best way to
perform clustering for
for example say
non-linear dimension
methods where
they also cluster or they also display
segregate samples based on their
neighborhood or based on their neighbor
nearest neighbor calculations
so we find the different clusters and
then we can look at the different
clusters or identity or evidence would
mean cluster so this is um
first five cells and their cluster level
identity so this is uh cell one there
yeah
identity one these are the cluster one
there is not much difference here but we
can when we go down we can see so we can
perform umap uh
we can run new map and then we can try
to identify different uh clusters we
have so we have looked we have been
looking for
different clusters and then we can see
that
see straight away see the difference
between
a linear transformation technique like
pca and non-linear transformation
technical view map that will work much
better for the data that we have
so yeah this we don't need to do this
and
when we go down we have to
use the
[Music]
user
umap
identifier distribution to find clusters
and we can use
this to identify marker genes that are
for clusters so
find markers function will do that for
that we have to
give
a
umap
object or we can give pca object or we
can give his knee object so much more
preferred
methods or preferred objects are umap
and listening for their ability to
distinguish between the um
ability to display the structures uh
that are hidden in the data set and yeah
this will tell
for which cluster we are going to find
marker and this is going to tell a
minimum percentage of the genes that are
that are that has to be found
um
in the
cells that we have so 0.25 would say
that if i identify
let's say these
genes has to be marker genes for my
clusters they have to be
present in 25 percentage of the cells
that contribute to these clusters so we
can do that and we can identify these
are the marker genes that is present in
the
in this clusters and then
we can perform the same for
next cluster one more cluster
this way but we cannot obviously do this
for all the different clusters so we can
use find all markers and
use
similar
threshold like
minimum percentage of identifying or
minimum percentage of observing the
genes in the number of cells that
contribute to the
clusters and also we can use
pole change threshold also in this and
then
we can
visualize their
clusters by grouping by clusters so uh
and therefore change and then
we have for example eight different
clusters and their
marker gene that
that will
characterize these eight different
clusters so since we have for example
maximum number of marker genes that we
have used only two so we have a
display top two uh marker g for each
cluster
so that's what we have you can change
this number to three to a display top
three genes for these clusters and uh
and there
average uh um
p values and average percentage
contribution and average uh log fc log
fall change can be identified uh here
so um
and then uh
yeah
we can actually visualize these markers
as i mentioned we can actually visualize
for example these
features are markers selected markers
for different clusters
this is yeah this is based on uh
logarithmic scale expression level we
can do the same for
uh
counts raw counts also and then this is
one of the most interesting uh feature
plot that we can will be used to we can
ah
we can
employ to identify or characterize these
uh features or these clusters and their
ability to uh
ability to annotate or to
identify different clusters
so a feature plot will do this and
and then we can use the heat map
visualization method simply to
see how different features are actually
contributing to
visualizing the difference in the
expression pattern that is observed by
different clusters so now we have to
assign um
cluster types for different clusters so
this this has to be done by for example
this has to be
done
externally so we have to take uh
for example these marker genes and
identify uh the cells that are uh that
these marker genes
our characteristics characteristic to
and then we can take
those cell types and then assign it to
the cluster id and then we can use the
new cluster ids or the names of these
identified cell types to visualize their
presence or visualize their segregation
in the disney or umap
visualization pattern and yeah and this
is
this we can do so this this one we have
to do it uh
externally and there are i think there
are also other
databases available to do this
if you give the
marker gene that will actually identify
different cell types also
that are also available so
i can take some questions uh when you
have because we have already exceeded a
lot of time
in
in explaining this that's why i did not
run everything each and every step umap
and other techniques will take a long
time to finish up in this
code block
so let me take some i take few questions
if you have
and i will
let you go through these
code block and we can actually
um
come back a day after tomorrow and if
you have any queries you can discuss
those queries or you can
contact me at supported find out bio
website let's
thank you so much dr raghav for such a
wonderful session
and it was good too sorry sorry sonalika
sorry to interrupt i will actually
include a link for another data set in
the collab notebook so uh you can have
the freedom of trying this out in a new
data set this is also a 10x based data
set i think it's a it's a neuro yeah
it's a brain
differential type data set so you can
visualize how different data set
can be employed in in a sewer package to
understand and annotate differential
types now yeah over to using liquor
sorry for it i forgot to tell this
thank you so much sir
and it's
good to see
the participants
uh still still
like being here for three hours and
going through this extensive workshop
i hope you were able to uh absorb the
concepts and go through some of these
things
and we'll share the recording with you
definitely
go through the concepts once again
revisit all the things that we discussed
today practice them and then when you
have any questions get back to us on the
main idea that dr raghav has shared in
the chat box it's support at the rate
find out bio
you can also reach out to us at
marketing advert on this logic.com
okay so now i wanted to discuss about
the registration steps so the first day
of the workshop was definitely a free
event for everyone those who have an
interest in single cell transcriptomics
and also transatomic data analysis
so we wanted to have you all join this
workshop and get an idea of what all the
workshop is about and how you can work
on these concepts and also get some
hands-on
right so today was just an introductory
uh session and it's just the beginning
we have the other two days for the
workshop as well where we will dig more
deep into these concepts and get a
better hands-on analysis and extensive
one and get working
also the people who register themselves
for the workshop will get an access to
the resources as india was telling that
you will have the access to the
omixlogic learn courses all of the
courses and also
the educational license will be given on
the t by info server where you can
upload your own data uh
from the big data repositories the
single cell data and also the transfer
communicator definitely and work on it
so now what are the steps to get
yourself registered for the workshop now
this is a three days workshop but the
access to the portal the our mixologic
learn training portal the r lessons and
also the t by info server will be for a
month
so this is one thing that that i wanted
to make it clear
now let me just quickly put the link to
the program page in the chat box
so this is the program page where you'll
be able to learn more about this
particular workshop and also you have
the whole schedule right so today we had
two sessions tomorrow we have the
session on what is singles and rna
sequence session we have two sessions on
uh 10th march as well i think one of
them is missing from here and i'll add
that up here
uh also i'll share the whole schedule of
the workshop once again by me
now if you scroll uh below in on the
same registration page you you'll find
three subscription levels one is a
beginner one the other is intermediate
and then we have an advanced level of
subscription
so now what are the subscription types
all about in the beginner one you will
have the access to the sessions that we
already had like the ones today
and uh in the intermediate subscription
you will have the access to the
symposium you will be able to become a
part of the symposium that we have on
march 31st and also
april 1st where we will be having
various speakers from various
organizations and also international
institutions and universities and
they'll be speaking about these research
trends data science bioinformatics uh
the role of a mixed data analysis
and also you will be able to become a
part of the poster presentation
competition if you would like to
and present your research work it has to
be your own research work that you that
you can definitely present in the poster
presentation competition so taking the
intermediate subscription level will
help you become a part of this research
symposium that i just uh told you about
now to learn about the symposium who all
will be the seekers who all would be
speaking what all you will be able to
learn and what it is all about you can
visit the page here
and putting it in the chat box also i'll
share via email
and then you have the advanced level and
in the advanced level you will have the
access to one-on-one mentor sessions
so uh these are group sessions that we
have as of now and the advanced
subscription you will be able to meet
the mentors one-on-one and take your
questions and align your research and
trust or any research proposal that you
might have and get started with your own
research work
so that was about these three different
types of subscription levels that you
can pick for yourself and become a part
of the workshop and leverage the
resources that we have on the portal and
get the access to the educational
license of the server as well
now talking about certification yes
definitely this workshop is certified
and after completing the workshop you
will be able to download your
certificate from the program page
express
so uh day after tomorrow when we have
the third day of the workshop and we'll
be completing uh the or like all the
resources and the sessions i'll tell you
like what steps you need to follow to
get yourself certified for the workshop
so that was all that i wanted to discuss
with you all about getting yourself
registered
only the registered participants will be
getting they'll be getting the
invitations for tomorrow and day after
tomorrow of the workshop
and uh yeah so that's pretty much that i
wanted to discuss
now if any questions are there you might
please put them in the chat box so that
we can answer
okay so there are no more questions i
think we are good to go and in today's
session and let's meet tomorrow
uh i am putting in the main address once
again
and you can reach out to us anytime and
also please make sure that these mail
ids are added to your address book or
contact list in your gmail
are uh because when we mail out uh the
interested participants sometimes the
mails land in promotion
like in the promotional box because we
are we are we have been interacting with
a lot of uh
students researchers and faculty so just
to make sure that you get the mail
please add these mail ids in your
address book or contact list in gmail
thank you everyone for joining and thank
you so much dr raghav once again for
such a wonderful session it was nice to
have you all with us here today and
looking forward to our next session
tomorrow thank you everyone have a great
day
thank you ryan thank you sri bhari